this is a production of cornell
university
so thank you all for coming and thanks
bill for the introduction
so i'm going to talk about population
genetics of my phytoplasms
phytophthora infestas is the causal
organism of green light disease that is
a disease that affects mainly potatoes
and tomatoes
it can grow on leaves stems tubers in
the case of potatoes and fruits in the
case of tomatoes
phytophthora infestance reproduces both
sexually and asexually
the sexual cycle serves like any other
organism
as a mode of survival and recombination
and
phytophthora intestines to be able to
reproduce sexually it meets two
different
organisms and these are called terms
a1 and a2 matin types and with when the
a1 and the a2 mating types
meet and then they recombine their
dna material they form an all spore
which is the sexual score
and this is a spore that serves as a
mechanism for survival because
it can resist a high temperatures very
low temperatures and it can survive in
the soil for many years
the asexual cycle on the other hand
accounts for population increase
and the asexual spore are the sporangia
this sporangia can germinate directly
or indirectly by releasing soil spores
and it can release up to 12 solar spores
and each of this source force is able to
cause an infection
so whenever the pathogen is able to
germinate indirectly epidemics are much
faster because instead of having one
infection set you can have
up to 12 infectious sites in the united
states phytoplankton intestines
reproduces mainly
asexually and that's why we have a
population that is very simple
composed only of a few clonal lineages
and clonal lineages
are all asexuals descendants
from a single individual and variation
within them arises by mutations
so how are these clonal lineages
determined
they are determined utilizing a set of
markers
so we have utilized an allosite test
we determine the mating type of the
individual
we do a restriction fragment left
polymorphism assay
using the a moderately repetitive dna
probe rj57
which can show differences between
individuals
most recently we're using 12
microsatellite markers
we have mitochondrial haplotyping and
nuclear gene sequences
in the united states over the past
40 years there have been approximately
24
different clonal lineages of phytoplasms
but in any particular year we only see a
few of this
for example since the late 1990s
u.s eighth quarter lineage is the one
that has been prevalent
and this lineage is a really good
pathogen of potatoes
it doesn't grow very well in tomatoes
and it's resistant to a very
useful or effective fungicide called
methanoxins
and because it is resistant to
methanoxan people stopped
using this fungicide in the late 1990s
so in 2009 the us was again
reminded of how devastating late flight
this
and this is the year that as bill said i
came here to do an internship so i
experienced
this epidemic and why was it so bad it
was bad because
tomato plants little siblings were being
shipped to all retail stores so lowe's
walmart was selling tomato plants that
were infected with the pathogen
and home gardeners and organic growers
were growing disinfected plants in their
homes or in their fields
and they helped disperse this disease
throughout the u.s
so in june 24 we
found our a professor in the department
he barely brought
a infected tomato plant to our lab from
one of these retail stores
and then by the end by mid august it was
all over new york state
so since i was here during this summer i
experienced
bill's face of panic and like doing an
emergency meeting
and he invited a doctor keith perry and
dr tom cedar to join this meeting
as well as the lab and i saw how worried
they were they were saying like
okay what's going on like all tomatoes
are dying what's different
what's happening and immediately i saw
like this was important
i just had like done things in the lab
but i forgot about
the impact the real input so people were
losing everything they were losing a lot
of money
so it was super important so that's why
i decided to come back in 2011
and figure out what what was this new
lynch
so as i had said before here i'm going
to show
the ice the genotypes that we have
received
in our lab from potato and tomatoes and
prior to 2009
us-8 which is this pink collar was the
dominant village
there were others but this was a
dominant one then in 2009
you can see that this red lineage which
we called us 22
started displacing us-8 and this us-22
was that same genotype that wasn't the
tomato seedlings that were being sold
everywhere
so it makes sense that humans help
disperse these diseases and that's why
we see this change but then in 2010 and
2011
we see that other new genotypes arise
these are us-23
in dark blue and us-24 in light blue
as well as this rare and diverse
genotypes which you can see in the
striped
bars which we had no idea what they were
so we i arrived in 2011 and i wanted to
figure out like okay
what is going on with this what what's
happening with phytoplankton
infestations in the u.s
so just to put you into context today
the situation is this
us-23 is displacing all of the other
genotypes and today us-23 is the
prevalent
genes so again we have 24 different
lineages but on a particular year
there's one that predominance
so my first research objective was to
investigate
epidemiologically important phenotypic
characteristics of the recently emerged
colonial lineages
this were us 22 23 and 24
and more specifically i wanted to know
what was the host preference of this
genotype
if temperature had an effect in the
germination
if germination rates differ among
lineages and if this isolate differ
in their sensitivity to the fungicide
methanox
so the first phenotype i studied was
host preference
and to do this i inoculated tomato and
potato leaflets
and i placed them at 15 degrees celsius
and after six days
i washed this leaflets with three
milliliters of water
and i counted angel so in this figure
what we're seeing here in the y-axis
are square energy counts and in the
x-axis we're seeing the
three the four different vintages i
studied i included usa
as a control because we already knew
what we were going to expect we knew usa
preferred to grow on potatoes
and indeed we can see that the gray bars
are potatoes the blacks are tomatoes
so we can see that usage correlates much
better on potatoes than it does on
tomatoes
but we learned that us 22 and us 22 at 3
were very good pathogens of tomatoes
and what's even more interesting is that
they were also able to grow a potato
and the us 24 was very similar to usaid
in that
it was able to grow better on potatoes
and not that greater tomatoes
the numbers that i have within
parenthesis represent the number of
isolates i used for genotype
so all of this i did it in the lab but
something that was really cool was to
see that when you separate
that figure i showed at the beginning
but here i've only included isos that
came to the lab from potato
we can see that we see us-8 and us-24
like dominating and these were the
lineages that refer to growth
on potato and then we can see that us-23
is very good pathogen of potato as well
and today
like most of the samples we receive are
from us 23
and you see how usaid that was very
important prior to 2009 is disappearing
on tomato we see that us 22 was
exclusively found in 2009 on tomatoes so
us-8
you can see us we haven't gotten a
sample of us-8 since 2009 growing on
tomatoes
there were a few isolates from us 24 and
tomato but very real
in comparison to those that came from
the table
the next phenotype i wanted to study was
the effect of
germinated temperature and germination
so as i had mentioned in the
introduction
um german direct germination is when the
sporangia
forms a germ tube and it infects it
penetrates the leaf and causes infection
whereas in direct germination the
sporangium releases eight sauceports and
each of this is able to germinate
so the epidemics are much more
aggressive if indirect termination is
happening
so how i did this experiment is i
inoculated
a microscopic slide slides with water
agar
droplets i put the inoculum of the sperm
oh i put sporangia in them
and then i placed those parents at four
different temperatures
10 15 20 and 25 degrees celsius
and after 16 hours i counted on the
microscope how many
esperanza were empty indicating that
those had germinated indirectly or how
many sporangia had germinated directly
so here in the continuous lines we see
that in direct germination
and what we can see is that at lower
temperatures in direct germination is
favored and as temperature
decreases sorry as temperature increases
in direct termination decreases
something that's also interesting is if
you see
at 15 degrees celsius us-8 and us-22
do not do that well i mean they don't
release as many solar spores
but us-23 and us-24 do
release more soil spores at 50. so
temperature
varies a little bit between between
genotypes
and in terms of direct germination we
learn it's not that common
but when it happens it happens more at
higher temperature
so we were interested in seeing how fast
our sporadic release in soil spores and
if some genus types release soil spores
more quicker than others
so i did a similar experiment but
instead of placing
the isolate at four different
temperatures i only placed it at a
single temperature
it was 40 degrees celsius and i had and
what i did is counted how many sperm
that were emptied
after 30 minutes 90 minutes 150 210
and 960 minutes and what we were amazed
because we didn't know that
before is that us 24 released
a soul sports by 30 minutes 80 percent
of their spranda were empty
so it's really quick at releasing
saucers whereas the other ones are
slower
so we still do not know what are the
implications of this but if you can
imagine a summer that has very short
periods of cold temperature
genotypes isolates belonging to
a genotype us24 are going to be favored
because they are going to be able to
release a lot of solar sports and are
going to be able to cause a lot of
infection
and finally the last phenotype i
assessed was sensitivity to methanoxy
and methyl oxen
is a phenylal fungicide that is widely
used against
almond seeds and it's believed to
inhibit the ribosomal rna biosynthesis
this is the same fungicide that we knew
usaid was resistant to so that's why
people stopped using it
to assess sensitivity to methanoxin
what we did was uh take isolates that
had never been exposed to methanoxan
and we then transfer them to plates with
no methanoxin which were our controls
other plates with low concentrations of
methanoxin and other plates with high
pressure high concentration of methanols
so for isolates that were resistant
basically how we assessed it is that
when
in the in our controls there were plates
that had no methanoxin when growth was
80 to 90 percent of the plate then we
measured the diameter of the three
different concentrations
and we reported growth here
relative to growth here so how much less
it grew here than here or how much more
grew here than here
so us8 is resistant and you can see that
it grows very well
at low concentrations and at high
concentrations
but us-22 is sensitive it doesn't grow
it grows very little at low
concentrations and almost nothing
at high concentrations and this is
something people did not know you in
2009 and that's why the epidemic was so
bad if people would have known that the
u.s turned into a sensitive they could
have again used the sponsorship and
saved a lot of money so we investigated
this
in u.s 23 and u.s 24 as well
and what i have in this figure is in the
bottom we
we have the concentrations of methanoxin
the white bars represent
growth at zero my with no methanoxan
so because this bars are relative to
those ones
the white ones you're always going to
see us as a hundred percent
and then you're going to see that us8 is
resistant whereas
these three lineages are sensitive
something that was very interesting is
we wanted to see whether
resistance or sensitivity was maintained
over the years
so here we have genotypes that we
collected in 2009
genotypes we collected in 2010 and
genotypes we collected in 2011
and we did again the same type of study
we inoculated each of those
at five and a hundred and we can see
that
for us eight for example
the resistance was maintained over the
years
and for us 22 23 and 24
isolates that were found in 2009 were
sensitive in 2010 as well and in 2011 as
well
and like that we decide for us 23 and
news 24.
so to conclude this first part of my
work
what we learned was that us-22 and us-23
were very good packaging of both
potatoes and tomatoes
whereas us-8 and us-24 were good
pathogens of material
we learned that all of the new lineages
22 23 and 24 were sensitive to
methanoxin
we also learned that 24 germinates
much quicker than the others indirectly
at lower temperatures
and this data was used by farmers to to
to apply informed management decisions
so for example
in 2012 this blue that
kind of gray blue that we see here is
lineage us11
so this is a lineage that we hadn't seen
since early 2000s but
it appeared again in 2012 and that
lineage grows
on tomato and potato and it's resistant
to methanol
so when when the farmers send their
samples to our lab we genotype them
and then they receive you have us 11 or
you have us 23.
so they call tour lab and they say okay
i received that i have us 23
should i spray or should i not and we
could tell them yes great because
it's sensitive but others that called
and said i have you as 11 can you pray
with me
we told him no don't spray because it's
resistant so people are really
thankful for this data because it helps
them make decisions that
save them a lot of money so
now going to my second research
objective
here i'm showing again the result for
methanoxin sensitivity
and and we see that us22 is sensitive
it doesn't it grows very little at 500
100
but there's some growth at 5.
so we were wondering okay what happens
if we take
a plug or a sample from the iso that
growing at five
and we transfer it to zero five and a
hundred again
so we are expecting to see this right
but instead
this is what we saw after yeah
i was going to say the results but so we
looked into the literature
and and we saw that other people had
reported this that there
there was some resistance after exposure
to sublethal concentrations of the
fungus
so we became very interested in this
phenomenon
and my second research objective was to
learn the characteristics of methanoxan
acquire resistance
so more specifically i wanted to know if
this phenomenon was unique
to us 22 or if it was more universal for
other strains
i wanted to know how fast did
methanoxaman fire resistance occur
and i wanted to see the gene expression
differences between
initially sensitive isolates and those
same isolates after they had a viruses
so again i'm showing usaid
in this figure what we can see is here
it's the previous exposure so it means
all isolates that are here have never
been exposed to methanoxan before
and they were then transferred to 0 5
and 100
whereas isolates that are here have been
previously exposed to 5
and then i transfer them to 0 5 on 100
and we can see
that for usa8 it is resistant and after
being exposed to methanoxan it continues
to be resistance
but for us 22 we see that at the
beginning acids that have never been
exposed to methanoxan
are sensitive to methanoxan but just
after a single transfer through
methanoxal containing media they
increase the resistance immediately
and so we wanted to know whether this
was unique for us 22 or for other
isolates
and we saw it for us 23 and u.s 24 the
same phenomenon occurred
after a single transfer through
methanoxan containing media either
low or high concentrations resistance
increased
for us 23 and u.s 24.
so is the phenomenon of acquire systems
unique to certain strains of my doctor
intestines it's not
it can happen at least in three
different sensitive originally sensitive
genotypes
how fast does it occur it occurs after a
single passage through metronox
containing media
and now we're interested in seeing the
gene expression differences between the
originally sensitive isolates and those
same ones
with acquire systems so to answer this
question
we used one individual of usaid which is
resistant
one individual of us 23 and two
individuals of us 24 which are sensitive
and we grew the isolated in pea broth
and we extracted
extracted dna rna from it p brock with
normal phenoxy
and then we took isolates that had
already been
transferred several times to 100
micrograms per milliliter of methanoxan
so they had already acquired resistance
we grew them on pbroth with 100
micrograms per milliliter
of methanoxan and then we extracted
their rna
and we sent everything to sequence and
we did three biological records
so from our rna sequencing we received
177 million reads
but then these were aligned to ribosomal
rna and transfer rna to eliminate
the contamination from this and we ended
up with 5.5 to 9.5 million reads
then we aligned it to the draft genome
of phytoplastis
and we were left with 4.6 to 7.8 million
rock pounds then we normalized to
account for the
size of the genes because bigger genes
are going to have more reads and smaller
genes
and after that we studied the
differential gene expression
so we were interested in knowing these
were the the sensitive isolates so we
were different we were
interested in knowing the differences in
gene expression between originally
sensitive acids and those same ones
after a fire system
so we compared that and we found 32
genes that were significantly
differentially expressed in response in
all originally sensitive isolate studies
so some of these genes were upregulated
among this there were 280p binding
cassettes
one phospholipase 11 conserved
hypothetical proteins some are excel are
effectors sprinklers
and endonuclear in the nucleus and
manitoba's hydrogenates
and some of the hypothetical functions
you know the atp transport a cassette
family or transporter so
it's logical to find transporters
because you can imagine that when you
expose an iso to stress it wants to get
rid of all these
toxins that it's going inside of them
and this zombie
dependent receptor has also been implied
with some antibiotic resistance
and then we saw some that were down
regulated
we still do not understand very well
like what these genes are how they are
implicated
i mean much more research has to be done
to understand this
but in conclusion all individuals from
all sensitive clinical lineage be
investigated became a tolerant of
methanoxin
and this tolerance occurred upon a
single transfer
through methanoxan containing media and
among the 32
genes that were different and truly
expressed there's some that could have
putative functions
involving stress responses and further
work will be necessary to identify the
precise mechanisms
underlying this so we have not observed
the fire assistance in the field which
is good news we saw that
isos that are sensitive have been
sensitive throughout the years
we inoculated some plants but there was
a lot of variants
so we didn't really see anything in
plants this is just an in vitro
observation and we think it happens
because
perhaps there is a fitness cost
associated with the acquire resistance
but we still need to investigate more to
really understand this
so now we understand a little bit more
about the prevalent
lineages of my copter intestines from
2009 to today
but now but what about this rare
and diverse genotypes that happened that
that we saw in 2010 and 2011.
so this rare and diverse genotypes were
found
mostly in new york state but some
individuals were found in pennsylvania
and in ontario canada
and if you see in this map with the red
lines i'm showing
counties where only the a1 mating type
was found
with the blue lines counties where only
the eight remaining type was found
and with the squares black squares
counties where both
a1 and a2 made in touch were found so
remember that
when a1 and a two main types are
together sexual recombination can have
and that is bad news so i want you to
look at this carefully because it
doesn't mean the fact that we are not
seeing an
a2 here because it either wasn't one our
sample size was really small
so it might have been by chance that we
didn't sample the a2
we named this genotypes gdt-1
through gdt20 and the
genotypes that i'm showing underlying
were those that were found in 2010
and the rest were all sampled in 2011 so
much more were sampled in 2011 and in
2010
and something that i also want to
highlight is that some genotypes the
ones that are involved
were found in multiple counties
so my third research objective was to
investigate the rare and diverse
genotypes of phytoplasms that were
detected in a region
around central new york i wanted to know
if this new genotypes
arose either by mutation migration or
recombination
and if they arose to recombination
if there could be any of parents
among the dominant lineages that we were
seeing in the u.s
so again the three possible explanations
for this scenario for
seeing this diversity remember in 40
years we have seen 24 different
genotypes in two years we saw twin so
that's weird
so there could be three possible
explanations either mutations
migrations or recombination we don't
think
mutation is a possibility because the
this
these genotypes were diverse for their
allosans their micro satellites
their restriction fragments polymer
fission their profiles
they were polymorphic for their nuclear
genes and they showed
diverse methanol sensitivity so they
were different in a lot of different
low side and larger so it's really
not likely that this could be explained
by mutation in such a short time
so mutation we don't think it is but it
could be migration
or recombination and migration is a
possibility for sure it could be that
these genotypes arose
somewhere else and they were all
transported either to tubers or tomato
seedlings
to numeric states and that's when we
found them in new york state
but to test whether they came from
recombination we did
a test that is called the index of
association that is
using the microsoft of hypnosis and this
test just proves the null hypothesis of
a recombination and we failed to reject
it so
this genotype might represent a
recombinant population
our next question was if one of the
dominant
clonal lineages could be one of the
possible parents
and in order to do this and this is how
it's done also for humans to see if
a child is the child of some terms so we
get a strength
and then we get our perpetual progeny
and what we do is we look at at
one locus at a time so if in that locus
they do not have any alleles in common
then
you that's not apparent of that project
but if it has one allele at least one
allele in common
then it might be apparent and then you
have to go to the next locus and do the
same thing
so here i have a concrete example this
is microsatellite dosa
i only have three loci here and what we
can see
is that for us8 the alleles which in
this case are numbers that are distances
uh i mean sizes the for usa
it has for the d certain locus a 108 and
112 alleluia
but among all these new genotypes there
were not
none of the alleles were either of this
so we eliminated usaid as a possible
parent
and doing the same type of reasoning we
eliminated us 23 and u.s spring 4
as possible parents but us 22 was not
eliminated
so further looking at other markers
because that was done with
microsatellites
us 22 share the same mitochondria
hablotype as in your genotypes
for the allosan glucose 6-phosphate
isomerase
the us-22 had a 100 and a 1212 yield
and the new types i had a 100 111 and 1
2012 u so this means that if us22 is
apparent the other parent had to
contribute with the 111a
but when we look at the nuclear genes
what we found
was that us22 could be apparent of some
but not of all of this new genotypes
and this is because us22 for three lossa
was homozygous for g t and g
whereas these three individuals were
homozygous for a different elite
so us 22 could not be the parent of this
real news but
it could be the parent of the other 17
individuals
we next wanted to study population
structure
and for this we included isolates that
have been prevalent in the us
at some point but we haven't seen over
the past 10 years
isolates that have been prevalent in the
us over this past
five years and the gdt isos and when we
do this analysis the analysis tells us
that we have two groups
we have one group in red that comprises
most all of the gdt isolates and one
group in green
that comprises most of the us references
what is
interesting is that us-22 seems more
similar to the gdt
than it does to any of the other us
reference sizes
but because this er software assumes
evolutionary models that are not valid
for by doctrine infestance
then we also run a discriminant analysis
of principle component
which does not take into account any
molecular
any evolutionary model and this was the
last one and this were done with
and what we can see is that as as the
other test
we see that gdt group with us 22
then we see the u.s reference isolates
but this one further differentiates us
from your us1
from the other axis so
in conclusion we found 20 rare and
diverse
genotypes composed of both a1 and a2
mating types in northeastern usa and
canada
in 2011. the gdt isolate seemed to be a
recombinant population
it seems that us-22 could be one of the
possible patterns
for this new genotypes but at least
other two parents
must exist we don't know who they are
and
if the gdp assets represent a migrant
population it's reasonable to think that
they arose at a single place and then
migrated to new york state
either through tubers or tomato
seedlings or
humans we don't know so that was
what we concluded for research objective
3.
now i hope that at this point it's clear
that
different genotypes of hydrogen
intestines even if they look similar
they are very different in their
responses to a lot of
different phenotypic traits so they
differ
very sensitivity to fungicides they have
different main
type mating types and they respond
differently to different hosts
and this is what farmers really want to
know i mean they i don't think they care
if they have us 11 22 or 23 they just
want to know should i spray should i not
if i have tomatoes should i be worried
or not do i have two of this or just one
that is what they want to know so what
we're currently trying to address
is if there are any genetic markers
associated with phenotypic traits
that would allow us to determine the
phenotype
within one day or hours instead of weeks
or months that is what it takes us to
do all of these experiments so there is
one problem and the problem is that for
any two isolates
there are millions of differences so how
do we know
which of those differences are the ones
that will tell us
this is what is sensitive to my finances
this one is resistant
so one of the ways to approach that is
by doing a genome-wide association study
and to do that we have sequenced six u.s
reference genotypes
18 gdt isolates 36 mexican iceland and
one european isolate
the mexican islands are very important
because mexico is believed to be the
center of
origin of phytoplankton intestines so
mexico mexican assets are very diverse
sexual
recombination occurs commonly like
it from every everything you sample is
probably an outcome of sexual
recombination
and in order to do a genome association
study you need
isolates that are diverse and are not
linked like the clones
and for all of these genotypes we are
phenotyping a
all of these traits so today i'm just
going to
focus on the phenoxin sensitivity and
effect of
temperature on dry weight because of
time and i'll just show the results for
the next communities
so again these are methanoxin
sensitivity acids
in the top we have growth at five
micrograms per milliliter low
concentrations of the fungicide
and in the bottom we have growth at high
concentrations of the chronic
and we can see that the mexican isolates
are super diverse so
if if you focus on this line this is
what the control group the control
through 100 because i'm showing this
relative to the controls
so in the mexican isis there's some that
grow better
in the presence of methanoxan than
without the penalty such as these ones
and there's some that are very sensitive
that they don't grow
not even like at five micrograms per
milliliter so this diversity is really
important and it's what we need to do
this type of studies
um effect of temperature on my cellular
mass
so here remember i was saying that for
germination low temperatures
favor the indirect germination and that
is good but for mycelial growth
my cell growth is favored at higher
temperatures
so we are interested in this phenotype
because
climate is changing and we know that the
summers are getting hotter
and we want to be able to predict which
isots are going to be
selected when temperatures are higher or
when temperatures are low
so what we did is we transferred the
isolate
to four different plates and we placed
them at four different temperatures
that were 10 15 20 and 25 degrees
celsius
and after six days we measured the
diameter of growth
and then what i'm presenting here is
growth
relative to growth at 15 degrees celsius
so for example we can see that isolates
grow
worse at 10 degrees celsius than they do
at 50 all of them
so they really do not like cold
temperatures to grow
but 20 and 25 we start seeing some
diversity some isotopes grow
really well at 25 better than 15
and others grow almost the same at 15
that at 25
so this is something that we think is
very important but we
have to investigate so these are the
phenotypic data but to sequence our isos
we are doing we did genotyping by
sequencing
what what this does is it takes the
whole dna of the isolate it cuts it with
restriction enzymes that favor
gene dense regions so hopefully it will
eliminate a lot of the repetitive dna
and then we send them to sequence
so our results were we sent 65 isolates
to sequence
most of these isotopes were sent in
triplicates or duplicates so that helped
us eliminate a lot of the missing data
that we have
we received 570 000
snips after merging and merging i mean
like
with the triplicates to have one single
genotype then we filter for proportion
of missing data and
minor allele frequency and we were left
with 98
000 snips so remember everything that i
have shown you before was with
12 markers uh
24 36 markers now we have 98
000 mark so this is important and what's
even more
cool i think is that after doing a
neighbor joining tree using those
uh snips we saw that a lot of the things
that have been proven in the past
were real so that was what we were
showing that expected to
to be confident on our data so
everything that is black here
are isolates that came from mexico and
what is in blue are isolates that are in
the u.s
so us 23 is very similar to an iso that
came from europe
and that was interesting because us 23
has also been found in europe so there's
some connection either
europe sends it to us or we send it
there we don't know but
there's a connection between those
islands us-7 and us-11 are close
together
is also very nice because
there are reports that us 11 is the
progeny of us7 and us6
then we find that all the gdt isotopes
are grouped together
but what's even more interesting is that
us-22 is the root
of this so it's further data to support
that
us-22 could be apparent although this of
some of these genomes
and then we see usa and us-24
that are together and they were very
similar at least scenario
but after looking at these trees some
something i
call uh my grandma attention was the
fact that
all assets that you see up here are able
to grow on potato and tomato
whereas the ones that broke here almost
exclusively grow entertain
so this is really interesting because
people have tried to
address this issue of post preference
for a long time
and there's almost like there's no clues
of what's going on
but at least here we have hypotheses and
we have a lot of markers that can help
us
understand these differences in host
practices
so this is my last slide and these are
the conclusions of all of my work
so first what we did we described the
epidemiologically important phenotypic
traits for the most prevalent
genotypes in the us we documented that
phytoplankton infested
is able to acquire resistance to in
vitro and it's important in vitro
because moles in this implant
we found evidence that suggests that
sexual reproduction might have occurred
in the us
and this is important because right now
sexual
reproduction is not dominant in the us
clearly but if it happens to become
common we're going to have to find
genetic determinants to
to understand phenotypic traits of
interest
in order to make isolate specific
recommendations
and with that i would like to
acknowledge my community members
bill is the best advisor i could have
ever dreamed of
and i'm really bad at this
and i bet this helped me a lot with uh
with my current research and michael has
also helped me
a lot and chip helped me a lot with the
population
and yeah
all welcome to colombia whenever you
want to come
this is very close to my house and it's
like that all year long so
if you ever want to have a christmas or
winter break
please please please come with me so i
think it's really appropriate that
somebody from a very warm climate should
have for a visa seminar
other questions
so is it still the case that you only
find a single
clonal lineage for each farm or outbreak
or whatever
okay ever find two in the same place
so the question is if from a farm
when we receive a sample from a leaf if
we find
one single genotype or more than one so
this year we found
right this year we found two at least
two different genotypes in a single leaf
but
that's very preliminary data so i don't
know how much
we can talk about because i mean i guess
what i'm getting at is the implications
of
getting a small sample from a farm and
saying yes you can spray or not
with ethanol yeah so
i think i think that's why we really
have to put
a lot of attention in what i'm currently
working on because
it's a matter of time until sexual
reproduction
can become dominant in the us i mean the
two main types are here
so we have been very lucky that
populations reproduce asexually mainly
and because of that we have been able to
manage the disease
easier but but i don't know if that's
going to be the case in ten or five
years
stuart do you have information
as to whether
in the um that you've seen over the
years
uh so the question is if i am aware of
any potatoes or seeds that might have
implications in the population structure
of phytoplankton that we see year
by year and i'm not aware of it and
it's it's hard to predict what assets
are we're going to see next year but
there's a lot of
explanations for example tubers that are
left
in the field and perhaps the soil didn't
get as cold so they survived or
volunteered plants that grow next year
but about like a seed source that
disperses them i
am not aware of it so i think we could
ask
keith and stewart if either of them
knows the seed source from those potato
growers
in western new york
so first congratulations on a really
impressive body of work and an excellent
seminar
my question relates to the mating
it's not prevalent in the u.s it's
prevalent in mexico
you say it's sort of a matter of luck
and it's just a matter of time before we
have
do you think it's luck or do you think
there are environmental factors that
affect me
anybody has looked at that i think it's
more
of a matter i was okay so the question
was why
in mexico do we see like sexually
reproduction occurring frequently and in
the us we do not
so a very like a good example is europe
in europe at the beginning isis migrated
from
the us running from mexico to the u.s
from u.s
to europe and during that migration
apparently no 82 main types went on the
a1s
so so in europe there was no sexual
production happening
then there was a second migration from
mexico to europe and in that migration
both a1s and atools
were sent to europe and because there
were a lot of a to making types i think
uh it's just chance of encountering i
think
more than more than environmental i
think it's chan it's probability
if they survive and if they arrive and
if they increase or
so places where it's 50 50 racial
have more chance of sexual reproduction
than places where you see that one
village is
one main type is dominating over the
other
if you take a methanoxin tolerant
variance of let's say us-22 and then you
passages in one
media
so we did that so our question is if we
have the isos with our fire
systems and then we transfer those
through methanol some free media
if we lose the upper resistance so we
did that
up to three passages to refinancing free
media
and we didn't lose it completely but if
you lose it
but not complete so they are still
persistent
have you tried passaging them through
plants
so we we tried to do that through plants
but well there was a lot of variation
i mean like sometimes the apart assisted
some
assets sometimes grew on the plants
sometimes they didn't the ones
with originally sensitive sometimes grew
sometimes didn't so we
so basically the answer is we don't know
we have to repeat those experiments and
because then your question is did you
actually we all had said you sort of was
seen implying that there was a mutation
that was occurring you think this is
actually a mutation
you know that isn't basically is
selected for when you can put them on
you know it's one generation of this and
all of a sudden
where is it some sort of epigenetic kind
of type modification of gene expression
that's
leading to the resistance so our
question is whether the acquire
resistance
could be because of a mutation or
because of an epigenetic mechanism
i personally think is an epigenetic
mechanism because it happens in multiple
genotypes and in different
individuals within genotypes so it's
highly unlikely that we get
like the same typical mutations so many
times and with a lot of different
ingredients
but i have no idea what it is and we're
trying travis talking in these days with
richard that is the undergrad
student that worked with me on that
here richard and we were really
interested in doing like an apartment in
my fire assistant
to paper and analyzing this because now
i have dna data as well this genotype
so so i'm going i can make like much
more accurate
analysis of this
a related question that is on on the you
can't was it
the screen 22 was secured a progenitor
or all these gtx where these cigarette
strains were
now you've got full genome sequencer
basically genome
sort of sequence by genome by
data from throughout the genome 98 000
snips can you go through and look at
the the segments within those different
strains that don't match
that you know the two strain because
then you could actually say
what because there's likely to be you
know a neighbor joining thing takes and
crunches all the genome down into one
single tree it ignores the fact that
different pieces of the genome have
actually
different phylogeny combinations
okay so the question is what if now that
i have like all the data
of of sequences of the whole genomes and
all the gdt's plus us 22 if i can go
over it and see like what parts of the
genome are shared and which ones are not
we're doing or an evolutionary model
because the tree i have here is a
distance tree
so it doesn't really take into account
mutations or
or models so yes if that's something
i've thought of but i haven't
i haven't started
was wondering if you wanted to speculate
on why
isolates become predominant and why
other isolates
disappear and presumably if you're
asking this question you have to think
of where they come from
and in potatoes presumably that would be
seed sources
okay so i have i have talked to bill
about this um
he tells me sometimes that i speculate a
little bit but this is my speculation
and it's like so if we go back to this
original
this figure we can see that sporulation
is much greater on tomatoes than a
potato
and that's why i've always thought that
being a pathogen that is able to grow on
tomato is
really good like if i wear a pathogen i
would want to go on
on tomato because they really make a lot
of spores and potatoes because of the
tissue
it dies so quickly that the packaging is
not able to sporulate that much
so the the good thing about being able
to grow on a potato is that you can
survive on the tuber
because on the other hand tomatoes don't
survive very well in the winter or not
at all
but if you're able to grow a tomato and
potato then you are like
the best character so here i remember
when we were doing this that i had
already
i thought i told kids like who kept this
yours coming through i said
i know it's gonna be like around for a
while and and we see it today and it's
everywhere and
that was something that i was just
saying like to make fun because i loved
doing this because there were so many
sports and i liked seeing that because
sometimes you never see anything like
here and it's very boring
so so i told that to and tolerate and
that was my reasoning but again
i mean u.s 22 disappeared completely
it's probably because us 22 we saw that
it wasn't it was just in a few potatoes
but it was mostly on tomatoes and
because tomatoes do not survive the
winter then
didn't have great chances of surviving
whereas the us-23
somehow happened to be in the potatoes
so it probably
arrived to the u.s potatoes or
that's my speculation
well if i were oh yeah um
i have you or can you look for a snip
that segregated
and so this is the problem with
phytoplankton okay doctors
draft genome has like a lot of scaffold
so if
i talker has 8 to 12 chromosomes but we
have no idea what the order of all of
this
are but if you see this there's like a
locust that seems to be promised so this
is a manhattan plot
so what i'm looking here is uh
scaffolds or like context of sequences
and then
here is the inverse in the log so the
more the higher it is the more
significant it is so the more markers
you see that are significant is because
there's something happening there that
that it's called that it's making an
association
and here we are comparing the a ones
versus the a to b
so if we eliminate all of this and just
keep the bigger scaffolds
we see this and we are and then we saw
some papers that had published
they were doing a amplified fragment
polymorphisms and they had identified
some loci that were
present in the a1 but not in the a2 and
we did a pcr
uh in silicon pcr
and and we saw that it was some of the
hits are in this
in this in this cathode so i mean this
very
beginning but we're we're trying to find
well thank you very much giovanna i
think it's a really fun seminar
and uh are you sure
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu